[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
بعد فرنسا بريطانيا لا تستبعد ارسال
المقاتلات
الى اوكرانيا جديده
قبل قمه الاتحاد الاوروبي في كيا
باوكرانيا تلمع صورتها بشن حمله واسعه ضد
الفساد تطيح بكبار المسؤولين
[موسيقى]
الخرطوم تعلن الاتفاق مع اسرائيل لتطبيع
العلاقات وكوهين يؤكدوا توقيع اتفاق
السلام هذا العام
تسجيل صوتي لمسؤول ايراني في حكومه روحاني
السابقه يحذر من انهيار النظام ويدعو
للاستعداد لمرحله ما بعد خامنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه بعد فرنسا انضمت
بريطانيا الى قائمه الدول التي لا تستبعد
امداد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله هذا يعني
مزيدا من التصعيد في الحرب وايضا المزيد
من الجدل في المعسكر الاوروبي موسكو لم
تخفي قلقها من دخول اسلحه الغرب المتطوره
الى اقرب نقطه لها سيما مع الزخم الاخير
في الدعم العسكري لكن يبدو ان اكثر ما
يثير خشيه الروس دبابات الالمانيه التي
اوشكت على الوصول بوتين تحدث عنها بشكل
صريح في كلمته بمناسبه الذكرى الثمانين
لمعركه ستالينغراد اتهم الغرب باعاده
القتال في اوكرانيا بايادي خلفاء هتلر عبر
هذه الدبابات وقال لدينا ما نرد به على
ارسال هذه الدبابات الى
للاسف نرى ايديولوجيه النازيه عادت لتشكل
خطرا مباشرا على امن بلدنا ونحن مضطرون من
جديد ان نجابه عدوان الغرب الذين يهددوننا
بدبابات الالمانيه ويريدون الان ان
يحاربوا في اوكرانيا على ايدي خلفائه هتلر
القلق الروسي لا يتوقف على الدبابات
فاحضان الغرب التفت حول كييف اكثر
والمساعده العسكريه زادت وفي جديدها اليوم
فرنسا قررت تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه رادار
للدفاع الجوي لتتبع الصواريخ والطائرات من
دون طيار القادمه من المنطقه المحيطه
بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه وزير الدفاع
الاوكرانيه
وصف نظام الرادار جراند ماستر 200 بانه
فعال للغايه وانه سينقذ ارواح الاوكرانيين
وفي الاثناء انضمت بريطانيا الى فرنسا
واعلن وزير دفاعها بين والاس بانه لا
يستبعد امداد اوكرانيا بطائرات مقاتله كما
ذكرنا قبل قليل لكنه اعتبر انها لن تكون
عصا سحريه تغير مسار الحرب بسرعه مضيفنا
ان بلاده منفتحه لبحث جميع انواع
المنظومات الحربيه مع اوكرانيا وليس فقط
الطائرات
الاسبوع الماضي قدمنا الدبابات وماذا بعد
ذلك يمكننا ان نعيد به نعد باشياء اخرى
كما قلت في مجلس العموم انا منفتح جدا
لبحث جميع انواع المنظومات وليس فقط
الطائرات لمساعده اوكرانيا هذه الاشياء لا
تحدث دائما بين عشيه وضحاها لكن يمكنني
القول اننا لا نعرض الاوكرانيين للخطر حتى
لو اعلنا تقديم طائرات سيستغرق ذلك شهورا
لا توجد عصا سحريه في هذا الصراع المروع
بخلاف الخطر الحقيقي للغايه هل متمثل في
ان شباب اوكرانيا يضطرون الى النهوض
والمضي قدما والقتال واستعاده الاراضي من
الرؤوس
تزويد كياف بطائرات مقاتله يبدو انه اصبح
جديا اكثر من اي وقت مضى خصوصا بعد حث
البرلمان الاوروبي على النظر في امكانيه
تزويد كييف بطائرات مقاتله غربيه وصواريخ
بعيده المدى قبيل القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه المقرره غدا الجمعه
المقترح الاوروبي ياتي في ظل اعلاني
واشنطن امس ايضا ارسال حزمه مساعدات تشمل
اسلحه وقنابل بعيده المدى
[موسيقى]
الزخم العسكري الذي وعد به الغرب لا يقل
زخما عن حده المعارك في الشرق الاوكراني
اللافت اعتراف واضح وصريح من كياب بصعوبه
الوضع وتقدم روسيا في الجبهه بل وتحضير
الاخيره لهجوم المحتمل كبير محللون رجحوا
ان هجوم الروسيه القادم سيكون الاكبر منذ
بدايه الحرب وفقا لصحيفه نيويوركيه تقرير
الصحيفه الغربيه اضاف ايضا ان موسكو قد
تستعد لفتح جبهه جديده حيث تسعى لتقدم
قواتها عبر الحدود الروسيه لاستعاده
الاراضي التي طردت منها في سومي او خاركب
بشمال شرقي اوكرانيا في حين تتاهب كيابل
للصد سيما في ظل معلومات ان موسكو تحشد
نحو نصف مليون جندي على الحدود وتكاثف
قصفها قبل ان تصل الدبابات والعربات
المدرعه وانظمه الاسلحه الاخرى الى الغرب
او من الغرب الى اوكرانيا
وفي مزيد من التحشيد الروسي اعلنت موسكو
وصول الروبوت العسكري ماركر الى المعارك
في دومباس نشاهد
معنى من موسكو مورسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا فلاديمير
بوتين توعد الغربيين بالرد على تزويدهم
اوكرانيا بالمزيد من الاسلحه هل هناك لما
يشير الى طبيعه هذا الرد الروسي المرتقب
مساء الخير صهيب نعم صحيح ما تقول بوتين
يتوعدو بالرد ويتحدثوا بان لدى موسكو ما
يكفي من السلاح ومن العتاد للرد على جميع
خطوات الغرب نلاحظ صهيب بان كلام بوتين
تبعه كلام للمتري ميدف نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي الذي تحدث بان هذا العام
سيشهد دعما كبيرا للقوات الروسيه دعما
لوجستيا ولعب ودعما جوهريا بالمعدات لقوات
موسكو ايضا لفروف تحدث عن هذه الخطوه وفي
اخر التصريحات السياسيه خرج بيسكوف منذ
نحو الساعتين وهو المتحدث الرسمي باسم
الكرمليل وقال بان لدى موسكو كل
الامكانيات وكل القدرات للرد على خطوات
الغرض
المعركه تحتدم في جنوب الاوكراني
واصل عن الجنوب الاوكراني لو سمحت عبد
الجواد عذرا المعركه
نعم المعركه تحت
ايضا ق
ائد مجن
ر تحت عن سيطره على مدينه نيكلايف وهي
المدينه التي شهدت اعمالا قتاليه طويله
ايضا تقارير عسكريه اوصلت لموسكو بقطع خط
الامداد للقوات الاوكرانيه في المنطقه
التي تصل الى اجليدار طبعا ايضا بيان
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تحدث عن تحييد عشرات
المقاتلين الاوكرانيين في مناطق مختلفه في
شرق وغرب على العموم يعني موسكو تستعد
لهذه المواجهه باكبر قدر حسب التقارير
الغربيه لكن حسب الاعلان الرسمي في موسكو
لا يوجد اي شيء يشير الى هذا الشيء بالرغم
من ان القراءه العسكريه والسياسيه في
البلاد تتحدث عن ان هذا الشيء قد يحدث
خاصه قد يحدث يا عبد الجواد تشير التوقعات
او التحذيرات الاوكرانيه
وزير الدفاع الاوكراني حذر من ان موسكو
تستعد بجديه بالغه لتجربه شيء ما الرابع
والعشرين من شباط فبراير وهو
ذكرى السنويه الاولى لبدايه العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
ولكن انت تشير على انه لا يوجد اي تحركات
عسكريه تشير الى معركه كبرى او شيء يعني
منتظر في هذا التاريخ
صهيب يعني المعركه الكبرى لا يمكن تحديدها
او حصرها خلال فتره موجزه كما نلاحظ خلال
الفتره الاخيره ومن بعض راس السنه يعني
الجديده بدات موسكو بتصعيد لهجتها
العسكريه وضرباتها ان كانت صاروخيه او
مدفعيه او تقدم لقوات فاجنر او قوات
دانيسك او قواتها التي تسيطر نوعا ما في
تلك المنطقه نلاحظ بان بيانات وزاره
الدفاع تتحدث عن سقوط المزيد من المناطق
في شمال غرب دانيسك لذلك طبعا وتيره هذه
المعركه هي مستمره وموسكو طبعا كما تتحدث
بانها ستقوم بالرد ولن تقوم ولن تكون
مكتوفه الايدي في حال قام الغرب بالفعل
بايصال هذا السلاح الثقيل الى الجانب
الاوكراني لكن النقطه الهامه صهيب لابد من
لفت الانتباه اليها بان موسكو تحاول طبعا
دفع القوات الاوكرانيه قدر الامكان نحو
الشمال لابعاد طبعا الجنوب الاوكراني
والمناطق التي تسيطر عليها واعلنت ضمها
الى الاتحاد الروسي قدر كي لا تصل
الصواريخ بعيده المدى او يعني لتتمكن
موسكو من استخدام انظمه الدفاع الجوي
ومقاتلتها في اعتراض ما يمكن تسليمه لكيف
من سلاح ثقيل عبد الجواد الرشد من موسكو
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
سبقت اوكرانيا زياره المسؤولين الاوروبيين
الى كييف لعقد قمه الاتحاد غدا الجمعه
بتحسين صورتها ومحاوله الاسراع في اغلاق
ملفات فضائح الفساد في البلاد فشنك
السلطات حمله واسعه واسعه لمكافحه الفساد
واكد مدير مكتب التحقيقات الحكوميه ان هذه
الحمله التي تضمنت اقالات لمسؤولين رفيعي
المستوى هي مجرد البدايه تحركات تاتي تحت
بند هدفين رئيسيين كما يرى محللون الاول
الحفاظ على الدعم الدولي لاوكرانيا
والثاني هو تعزيز محاوله الاوكرانيين
للحصول على العضويه الكامله في الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكن يبدو انها بالفعل المجرد
البدايه فنحن نتحدث عن قضايا فساد ضخمه
وطويله الامد على ما يبدو في اوكرانيا
وعدد كبير من المسؤولين متورطون فيها
فاليوم قضت محكمه اوكرانيه بحبس نائب وزير
الدفاع السابق على ذمه تحقيق فساد في
مشتريات عسكريه
وكانت وسائل الاعلام الاوكرانيه نشرت
لقطات لعمليه تفتيش في منزل نائب وزير
الدفاع السابق في البلاد حيث تم العثور
اثناء عمليات البحث عن مبلغ كبير من المال
مخزنا في الاريكه
[موسيقى]
هذا الكثير من المال كما اعلنت الحكومه
الاوكرانيه هذا الاسبوع اقاله مسؤولين
كبار على خلفيه قضيه فساد تتعلق بعمليه
شراء امدادات للجيش باسعار مبالغ فيها
بالاضافه الى قضايا اختلاس في اكبر شركات
استخراج وتكرير النفط واتهامات بالفساد
لرئيس وزاره الدفاع بعمليات شراء سترات
واقيه للجنود وكانت هذه السترات دون
المستوى وخلال حمله المداهمات حققت
السلطات مع رئيس مصلحه الضرائب في كيف
الذي يزعم انه كان جزءا من مخطط للتغاضي
او يزعم انه كان جزءا للتغاضي عن مليار
و200 الف دولار امريكي من الضرائب غير
المسببه علما انه في منزل رئيس مصلحه
الضرائب عطر من قبل عثر مكتبه تحقيقات
الحكوميه الاوكرانيه عثر على مئات الالاف
من الدولارات ايضا
المخباه وساعات وسيارات فاخره
معنا من ثياب عبر سكايب بلودوم
الدبلوماسيه السابق سيد اهلا بك معنا في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه كما شاهدنا كميات
مهوله من الاموال
ساعات فاخره وسيارات فارهه كذلك تم حجزها
في هذه المداهمات في الكشف عن الفساد في
اوكرانيا هل هذه الحمله هي مخافه ان يتوقف
الغرب عن دعم اوكرانيا
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اخواني
[موسيقى]
في حمله الاعتقالات هذه هو الاعتقالات
كذلك ما هو الا شيء يسير من جبل الجليد
ربما بالنظر الى التقارير تتحدث على انه
مستويات الفساد تعدت دائره المسؤولين
الضيقين الى مسؤولين كبار كما تابعنا
اليوم ما هي الاسباب ما هي اسباب استفحال
ظاهره الفساد في اوكرانيا واوكرانيا في
حاله حرب كما نعلم
بصراحه
في اوكرانيا هذا التراث من
ايامات السوفياتي
كما نحن نجد بان الفسطاط موجود حتى الان
داخل اوكرانيا وخاصه خاصه في ايام حرب
وكلنا كنت قبل غير مقبول هنا في مجتمع
اولا وثانيا كمان سؤال مطروح على طول
مجتمع اوكرانيا لماذا لما تكون اي مكافحه
انما فساطه وخاصه في وزاره الدفاع قبل حرب
يعني نحن بان كل هذه الاصلاحات وخاصه
اصلاحات القضائيه كما تطلب كما تطلب
الاتحاد الاوروبي الانضمامي كمان
الاصلاحات الاخرى الصعبه جدا في ايام
الحرب ولكن على كل حال من الضروري مكافحه
مع فساد بدون اي استثناء نعم طيب نقطه
اخرى تبدو مهمه هل تعتقد ان الاوروبيين
مقتنعون بان ما تقوم به اوكرانيا هو كافن
في مجال مكافحه الفساد خاصه قبيل هذه
القمه في كييف
للاوروبيين غدا الجمعه وطبعا مع مساعي كيف
للانضمام الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
بالمناسبه بكره نحن سوف نشهد تقييم من
وفضه من ورقه اتحاد اوروبي حاول تحقيق
لاوكرانيا واجبات
ومعايير لانضمام لاتحاد الاوروبي ومنها
مكافحه مع فصاد ومنها اصلاحات في مجال
القضائي
يعني بكره نحن سوف نشهد كل شيء ولكن للاسف
الشديد فيقول هذه الفداع مع فساد يتاثر
جدا على الصومعه اوكرانيه وكمان على صنع
السيد
ولكن انا عليه قيمه بان هذا لن يتغير ان
مسيره حرب وسوف يكون مساعدا من الغرب ولكن
سوف تكون مراقبه كبيره وشديده على كل
المصروفات الاوكرانيه شكرا جزيلا لكم
دبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه السابق كنت معنا منك
[موسيقى]
وقبل ان ننهي ملف اوكرانيا في اخبار
الساعه نتوقف مع تصريحات اللافته اليوم
لوزير الخارجيه الروسيس الذي قال ان الغرب
يتطلع لتكون مولدوفا اوكرانيا التاليه كما
اشر لابرف في مقابله مع قناه روسيا 24 الى
ان الغرب يريد تحويل جورجيا الى مصدر
ازعاج اخر لروسيا
[موسيقى]
ليس لدي شك في انهم يريدون ايضا تحويل
جورجيا الى مصدر ازعاج اخر واعاده الوضع
الى سابق عهده انهم يختبرون مولدوفا لدور
مشابه الاوكرانيا المشروع مناهض لروسيا
محتمل رئيس يتوق الى الانضمام الى الناتو
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه العربيه ترصد
اثار القصف الايراني على مقر احزاب
المعارضه في كردستان العراق
[موسيقى]
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي
كوهين ان زيارته للسودان ترسل اسس الاتفاق
سلام تاريخي وخلال مؤتمر صحفي عقب عودته
من الخرطوم اكد كوهين ان اتفاق السلام مع
السودان سيعزز الاستقرار الاقليمي والامن
القومي لاسرائيل فيما اوضحت وزاره
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه انه من المنتظر
توقيع اتفاق السلام مع السودان هذا العام
في واشنطن بعد تشكيل حكومه مدنيه
معنى من القدس مراسل العربيه زياد حلبي
زياد اهلا بك معنا انت كنت معنا في نشره
سابقه في الترجمه الفوريه للمؤتمر الصحفي
لوزير الخارجيه الاسرائيلي عقب عودته من
السودان اهم ما قاله
تحدث عن ان الجانبين كبدلا مسوده الاتفاق
الاتفاق هو قصير تقريبا من صفحتين ولكن
يستند ايضا الى اتفاقيات ابراهيم التي
وقعت عليها السودان لكنها لن تستكمل
الانضمام الى هذه الاتفاقيات
وبالتالي قال ايضا ان هناك رمزيه بالنسبه
لاسرائيل في العلاقات او في توقيع اتفاق
التطبيع علاقات مع السودان تحديدا لانها
البلد التي شهدت قمه اللاءات الثلاث لا
للمفاوضات لا الاعتراف باسرائيل ولا
للسلام باسرائيل وقال انها اصبحت الان نعم
الثلاث عمليا لان الامور باتت عكسيه تحدث
في صالح هذا الاتفاق وما سي يعني
ولكن يجب ان نتوقف عند هذه النقطه
لماذا هذا الاتجاه العكسي الان صحيح ان
المسار تطبيق العلاقات بين السودان
واسرائيل بدا منذ سنتين ولكن الان هي اول
زياره رسميه معلنه لمسؤول اسرائيلي الى
السودان لماذا الان في هذه المرحله المضي
في اتجاه التطبيع الرسمي للعلاقات
عمليا هناك محاوله اسرائيليه حديثه لانجاز
هذا الاتفاق تم الاتفاقات الاخرى مع
الامارات والبحرين في حينه وبالتالي هم
يحاولون منذ وقت طويل وهذه الزياره هي
الثانيه الرسميه الوزير ذاته كان في
السودان عمليا بعد شهرين من توقيع
اتفاقيات ابراهيم ولكن كان وزيرا للشؤون
الاستخباراتيه عمليا في ذلك الوقت اليوم
ياتي يذهب كوزير الخارجيه عمليا لا جديد
كثير في هذه الزياره حقيقه
وعمليا ربطت بتشكيل حكومه مدنيه في
السودان ضمن الحكومه المدنيه زياد ان شكلت
هذه الوقت رجاء زياد السوداني يمر حاليا
بفتره الانتقاليه وهناك بعض الملفات
العالقه ما بين المكون العسكري والمكون
المدني في السودان ما هو الموقف
الاسرائيلي حيال هذا الا يمكن ان يؤثر هذا
المضي قدما في مسار التطبيع
بدون ان شك وهو اساسا ما منع في المقام
الاول السودان من التوقيع على اتفاقيات
ابراهيم في حينها
وبالتالي هذا يؤخذ في الحسبان في اسرائيل
يعرفون تماما بان هذه الامور العالقه يمكن
ان تؤجل هذا الامر كما حدث لمده سنتين منذ
اعلان اتفاقيات ابراهيم ولهذا قد لا
يتفاجئون ان لم يكن خات نهايه العامه
حكومه مدنيه زياد حلبي مباشره من القدس
شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
ابقت الحكومه الاسرائيليه على قرارها لهدم
قريه الخان الاحمر شرق القدس لكن مع تاجيل
الهدم حتى الصيف لتبقى امال السكان معلقه
على امل ضغط دولي يجنب السكان التهجير
القصري
لا غرابه ان تجري هذه الطفله حافيه في هذا
الجو البارد والماطر انه دفء المكان الذي
ولدت فيه رغم انها باتت تدرك وفي هذا
العمر الصغير انه قد يفقد في اي لحظه هذا
ما قاله لنا سكان القريه البدويه الخان
الاحمر ان اطفالهم يوجهون لهم اسئله
مصيريه لا يملكون لها اجابه احنا عايزين
لنفهم اطفالنا فلا صغار يعجزوك في الاسئله
احنا عايزين نفهمهم كل ما تدخل سياره ما
يشوف اي شيء وراحوا يعني ما انت متريح لا
في الليل ولا في النهار للمره التاسعه
تضطر الحكومه الاسرائيليه لتاجيل تنفيذ
امر هدم واخلاء الخان الاحمر الذي اقرته
المحكمه الاسرائيليه
ورغم ان جمعيات استيطانيه وضعت حكومه
نتنياهو في الزاويه قضائيا لتنفيذ الاخلاء
الا ان الضغوط الامريكيه كانت اقوى هذه
المره فهذا التجمع البدوي المبني من بي
صفيح اصبح بقاؤه يعني بقاء خيار حل
الدولتين هنا ممر هنا مركز السلام ليس انه
بيت موجود هنا لانه اذا تم اقتلاع هذه
القريه سيتم هناك بناء المستوطنين قطعه
الضفه الغربيه شمال وجنوب الفريق الامريكي
السياسي والامني الموجود في المنطقه نجح
في اول خطوه نحو التهدئه لكن المهمه تبدو
معقده وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي لم يستجب
للضغوط وقرر اقتطاع نحو 30 مليون دولار من
اموال الفلسطينيين فيما يواصل بنجافير
اجراءاته العقابيه بحق الاسرى الفلسطينيين
في السجون ما يهدد بانفجار ميداني في اي
لحظه
تتوقفهم الاطماع الاستيطانيه وتهديدات
بنجافير من جهه والضغوط الامريكيه
والمساعي الاوروبيه من الجهه الاخرى ورغم
كل هذا الواقع الصعب والمستقبل المجهول
ينجح هؤلاء البدو حتى هذه اللحظه في
البقاء على ارضهم من قريه الخان الاحمر
عبد الحفيظ الوطن العربيه الاراضي
الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
الاحتجاجات في ايران وان خفز خمها في
الشوارع لكن الاحتقان الشعبي لا يزال
موجودا تقارير اعلاميه حقوقيه كشفت ان
السلطات الايرانيه اعتقلت ما لا يقل عن
185 شخصا خلال شهر يناير الماضي في
بلوشستان ايران رجح ناشطون حقوقيون ان
يكون المعتقلون حديثا في مدينه زاهدان
اعلى من 185 بسبب الاجواء الامنيه الشديده
وحملات الاعتقال واسعه النطاق اضافه الى
انقطاع الانترنت في سياق متصل افاد موقع
هانجا والحقوقي عن اعتقال ما لا يقل عن
182 مواطنا كرديا خلال الشهر الماضي في
مختلف المدن الكرديه في ايران في موازاه
ذلك اظهر مقطع فيديو استمرار الاحتجاجات
في اصفهان حيث ردد الاهالي شعار وراء كل
قتيل الف شخص وذلك ضمن الاحتجاجات ضمنا ضد
النظام
[موسيقى]
كشف تسجيل صوتي جديد عن مخاوف رسميه من
احتمال انهيار النظام الايراني بفعل ما
يجري وفي التسجيل الصوتي حذر محمد رضا
صالحي وهو المساعد السابق لمؤسسه الرئاسه
الايرانيه بحكومه روحاني خلال اجتماع
المحافظين الاخير حذر من الانهيار الداخلي
للنظام مطالبا بتحديد صلاحيات خامنئي ياتي
ذلك في وقت تستمر الاحتجاجات والاعتقالات
والمحاكمات
بعد اكثر من اربعه اشهر من الاحتجاجات
المتاعب التي يواجهها النظام الايراني
تتفاقم تسجيل صوتي جديد للمساعد السابق
لمؤسسه الرئاسه الايرانيه بحكومه روحاني
محمد رضا صالحي وفي اجتماع المحافظين
الاخير كشف مخاوف من الانهيار الداخلي
للنظام مطالبا بتحديد صلاحيات خامنائي بما
في ذلك بند الولايات المطلقه
يجب توجيه المرشد بخصوص الظروف الحاليه
والمستقبليه للبلاد المرشد يبلغ من العمر
نحو 80 عاما حتى لو عاش بعد 100 عام اخرى
هناك نهايه من سيجرؤ على اجراء الاستفتاء
ستتعطل العديد من قوانيننا وهي معطله الان
من الضروري تقويه البعد الاشرافي للقياده
وتقليص نطاق صلاحياته التنفيذيه من
الضروري تعديل الدستور على اساس تقويه
اركان الجمهوريه وتعزيز حق الشعب في
السياده من خلال الانتخابات وزياده
صلاحيات المؤسسات والمنتخبين والخاضعين
للمساءله في اثناء ذلك الاحتجاجات في كل
المناطق لا تهدا ففي ابضنان بمحافظه ايلام
غربا رفع المحتجون شعار الموت للديكتاتور
واغلقوا الشوارع باشعال النار ليلا وفي
محافظه اصفهان ايضا ردد المحتجون شعارات
مناوئه للنظام ليلا قابلت ذلك حمله
اعتقالات واسعه شامله نطاقها كل جغرافيا
البلاد ما لا يقل عن
367 مواطنا بلوشيا وكرديا تم اعتقالهم من
قبل قوات الامن الايرانيه خلال شهر يناير
المحاكمات هي الاخرى لا تتوقف 14 محتجا
تمت احالتهم على المحكمه بتهم قتل عنصر من
الباسج في طهران ويواجهون احكاما قد
تقودهم الى حبل المشنقه بلال البشتين
العربيه
من بروكسل تنضم الينا صحفيه الايرانيه منى
السيلاوي منى اهلا بك معنا في اخبار
الساعه ما مدى اهميه هذه التصريحات التي
وردت في هذا التسجيل الصوتي الذي حصلت
عليه ايران انترنت لمحمد رضا صالحي
لازم نفرح انه حدا من داخل ايضا
مقتنع بما نقول انه بالفعل في ازمه هناك
احتماليه
هو محمد رضا صالحي يبقى مسؤولا سابقا هل
هل هذا ينقص من اهميه هذه الرؤيه حتى وان
كانت من داخل ايران
لا ينقص منها ولكن لازم اقول اما هو منافق
اما هو متوهم يعني منافق لانه هو كان في
حكومه حسن روحاني في حكومه حسن روحاني حسب
رويترز 1500 شخص ماتوا خلال اسبوعين في
احتجاجات
ارتفاع سعر المحروقات يعني هو كان مسؤولين
هناك كيف لما كان هم مسؤولين لم يقولوا
هذا الكلام ولا يتحدوا المرشد ولا قاموا
باي اصلاحات اساسا عندما كانوا في السلطه
ام هو متوهم يعني لا يعرف المرشد العالي
ولا يعرف النظام البلاد يطلب من مرشده
اللي متحكم في كل مفاصل البلاد يعني 60%
من اقتصاد الايراني في شركات التابعه
للمرشده على هو ترك يده حرس الثوري يعني
حر بكل الاماكن يعني اكيد هو يعرف مرشد
الاعلى من المستحيل اساسا هنا عندما تحدث
على
تغيير او الغاء مفرده المطلق في الماده 57
من الدستور عندما تحدث عن تقليص سلطات
خامنه هل تقصدين هنا انه يعني ان هذا
المطلب غير واقعي الان في هذه المرحله هنا
يعني بالنسبه لواحد مثل خامني من المستحيل
يقبل هذه التنازلات على العكس من ذلك كل
تصرفات الخامنيه المؤخرا يبين انه هو يريد
ان يوسع الولائيين له حتى يستمر في الحكم
ويستطيع ان يسلمها الى ابنه فمن مستحيل
يحدد من صلاحياتها العكس من ذلك الان يزيد
من صلاحيته من خلال تاسيس شراء القوات
الثلاثه من خلال سن قوانين لا يحقه ان
يصنق قوانين من المفروض مرشد على لا يكون
لديه اي دور في اي اطار يمكن ان توضع هذه
الرؤيه ما قاله محمد رضا صالحي خاصه انه
في التسجيل الذي اعود واكرر نشرته ايران
انترناشونال هو عقد في الثلاثين من يناير
يعني هو ما يزال حديثا وحضره ايضا اسحاق
جهنجيري النائب الاول لحكومه روحاني هل
يؤشر هذا ربما الى وجود تيار داخل ايران
او دعينا نقول يمكن جناح اخر في النظام
برؤيه التغيير رؤيه ما يطالب به المحتجون
الايرانيون
اللي صارت ولكن انا اقول ممكن تحليلي انه
هؤلاء يعرفون تغيير قادم
احتماليه الثوره موجوده هو حتى قارن الوضع
الحالي الايراني بالاتحاد السوفيتي اخر
باخر سنوات فقال لم ينهار الاتحاد
السوفيتي بسبب الثوره ولكن كان كل يوم
الناس بازمه يوم ما في كهرباء يوم ما في
ماي يوم ما في غاز نحن الان نعيش هذه
الازمه لذلك انا اظن الاصلاحين لديهم تخوف
انه سيكون هناك تغيير ومن خلال هذه يعني
التسريحات يريدون ان يحافظون على بعض من
المكانه لدى الشعب لانه يعرفون في حل غرض
النظام ولم يقولوا هذه التصريحات لا يكون
هناك اي لهم اي دور في المستقبل ولكن هذا
الشعب يقبل هذه التصريحات اللي هي بالفعل
يعني
ملفتني في هذا التسجيل لمحمد رضا صالح
حديثه على انه من ضمن الخيارات للتغيير
تحدث عن امكانيه التدخل الاجنبي لتغيير
الوضع داخل اير الى اي حد يعني هذه النقطه
لافته عندما يتحدث مسؤول سابق وكبير يعني
هو من حكومه روحاني السابقه
احد السناريحات ان يكون تدخل خارجي وهو
يقول لا اتمنى ان يحصل يقول احد
السيناريوهات الموجوده اللي ممكنه ان تحصل
هي تدخل الخارجي لذلك يقول من الافضل
النظام يقوم باصلاح نفسه يقوم ببعض
الاصلاحات مثل حصر دور مرشد الاعلى بشكل
انه حتى الاولاد صار لدينا مرشده على بعد
خامني لا يكون له دور المطلق لا يكون له
كل هذه الصلاحيات حتى ممكن ان نستمر على
هذا النظام لانه اذا استمرينا في هذا
الوضع الحالي سيكون هناك انحيار حتى من
دون حتى تدخل الخارجي
طيب سؤال اخير هل يستمع النظام الايراني
لهذه الرؤيه ام لا هو ايضا في في ما تسرب
قال الرئيس الشرطه اشتري اللي غيروه بعده
حطوا رادان في البدايه قال انه انا خلونا
نروح انا نروح على التلفزيون الرسمي اعتذر
واغير لك كم شخص يعني يفصل لي كم شخص عن
عمل هو احل هاي القضيه قتل
ابدا المرشد ما مستعد يتنازل يعني حتى لم
يترك شخص اخر عنه يعتذر ويخمل هذه
الاحتجاجات من السيلاويه صحفيه الايرانيه
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
لا يتوقفوا النظام الايراني عن ملاحقه
واستهداف الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني المعارض غارات عده شنتها طهران
ضد مقر الحزب ومؤسساته التي يخشى النظام
من تاثيرها في الداخل العربيه وضمن
تغطيتها الحصريه تفقدت المكان ونقلت صورا
تظهر حجم الدمار في مقرات باتت مهجوره
[موسيقى]
نشق طريقنا وسط هذا الدمار في هذا المبنى
الذي عرف بالقلعه قبل اشهر فقط كان حصنا
ومقرا لمعارضين ايرانيين لكنه لم يكن
منيعا ضد ضربات النظام الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني الايراني
اقدم واهم الاحزاب الايرانيه المعارضه من
هنا من قلعه في كردستان العراق كان يدير
عمليات السياسيه وما تتبعه من منظمات
طلابيه شبابيه ونسائيه لكن هذا المقر
كثيرا ما كان يتعرض لضربات ايران يزدادت
الضربات مع المظاهرات الايرانيه الاخيره
واتهام ايران لهذه الاحزاب باداره وقياده
المظاهرات التي انطلقت في ايران منذ اشهر
ولم تهدا الى غايه الان اذا هذه بقايا احد
الصواريخ الايرانيه يقول السيد امانجو
وقيادي في الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني المعارض بان هذه القطع الصغيره
هي قطع معدنيه الهدف منها هو ايقاع اكبر
قدر من القتلى في هذه الضربات الايرانيه
[موسيقى]
تم قصف هذا المكان ومخيم اللاجئين
والمدارس بصواريخ النظام كانت المدرسه
تستضيف 220 طالبا في غضون ذلك قصف النظام
ايضا حزب كوما وحزب الحريه الكردستاني قصف
النظام الاحزاب الثلاثه في نفس الوقت قصفت
هذه القلعه بسبعه وثلاثين صاروخا بالاضافه
الى طائرات مسيره الانتحاريه
منذ استقر الحزب الديمقراطي الكردستاني
الايراني في العراق في تسعينات القرن
الماضي كانت مقره اهدافا دائمه لضربات
طهران لكنها مع اضطرابات الداخل الايراني
باتت اشد واقصى نظام الايراني يخاف من هذا
الثوره ويخاف من سياسي الشعب الكردي في
ايران
[موسيقى]
استهداف مدرسه للاجئين ومواقع السكنيه في
كويسنجق او كويا وهذا الاسم الكردي
للمنطقه جعل السؤال عن الغايه الايرانيه
مشروعا اذكر الاحوال على سبيل لهم الى
البقاء في حاله استنفار دائمه
التي ترونها هنا تحرس مخيمات اللاجئين
والعائلات الموجوده قواعدنا العسكريه
الرئيسيه قريبه من الحدود وهذا المكان
موقع مدني لتقليل مخاطر الهجمات بالصواريخ
والطائرات المسيره وزعنا قوه البيشمركه
للدفاع عن المخيمات
يجزم المعارضون الايرانيون انجيلا يتهجى
الحريه والديمقراطيه اكثر ازعاجا للمرشد
ونظامه الذي يسعى لخنق اصواتهم ومطالبهم
مطالب تردد صداها في مظاهرات ايران
الاخيره
ساره بنعيشوبا العربيه كويستنج كردستان
العراق
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بعد ازمه
الدولار اوراق نقديه مزيفه تنتشر في
العراق وتثير قلق المواطنين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اعلنت وكاله الاستخبارات
العراقيه القبضه على اربعه متهمين قاموا
بتحويلات ماليه غير رسميه كما قالت
الوكاله انها صادرت اكثر من 270 الف دولار
بالاضافه الى 660 مليون دينار عراقي في
اربع محافظه
القى جهاز الامن الوطني القبض على مجموعه
من اصحاب الشركات الكبيره التي تقوم
بالتلاعب والمضاربه بالاسعار فضلا عن
تهريب العمله العمليه تمت بعد جهد
استخباري واوامر قضائيه وستبقى مستمره حتى
القبض على جميع الاهداف وتاتي هذه العمليه
ضمن جهود وخطه الحكومه في السيطره على ملف
تهريب العمله بعد ضربه انخفاض العمله
العراقيه امام الدولار ضربه اخرى في صميم
الاقتصاد العراقي حيث تداول العراقيون
تحذيرات من انتشار عمله مزيفه من فئه 25
الف دينار في السوق فيما التقت
الاستخبارات او القت القبضه على متهمين
قاموا بتزييف وتهريب العمله
كميه ضخمه من المزور موجوده بالسوق احنا
شو نسوي الدينار العراقي لا ثقه فيه
عراقيون يشككون في الاموال منه المزور
بدقه عاليه والاخر سهل الكشف فئه الخمسه
والعشرين الف دينار منتشره في السوق مزوره
ومتداوله
العراقيون استفاقوا على المحظور تحذيرات
من فخ التزوير وغيرها فيديوهات تعليميه
لكشف التزوير النجمه شايفينها هاي تقلبها
صفح الظل تحاول بها يطلع عندك كلمه العراق
اذا طلعت كلمه العراق هاي تعتبر مو مزوره
ذهول في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الدينار
بين التزييف وتخفيض قيمته امام الدولار
واتهامات لايران بتورطها في ذلك عبر
اذرعها في العراق الاطار هرب الدولار
هاشتاج وجد فيه عراقيون مساحه للتعبير عن
السخط والسخريه مستشار الحكومه العراقيه
نفى للعربيه ما هو متداول عن تزييف العمله
مشككا في صحه الاخبار فيما اكد ان ما
يدوره هو محاولات فقط لافتعال الازمات
واثاره الشارع العراقي غيداء السالم
العربيه
[موسيقى]
منذ استلامها مقاليد الحكم في افغانستان
لم تفي حركه طالبان باقل الوعود التي
قطعتها على نفسها
فتشددها وتعصب افكارها تجاه الشعب
الافغاني يزداد فاصبح الخناق يلف اعنقه
النساء فيها وفي اطار الرد الدولي على
قيود طالبان ضد النساء ومنعهن من التعليم
الجامعي والوظائف الحكوميه اعلنت واشنطن
فرض قيود جديده على منح التاشيرات لافراد
حركه طالبان كرد على قراراتها الاخيره
المجحفه بحق النساء الافغانيات وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه اكد ان بلاده ستواصل
العمل بالتنسيق مع دول حليفه بهدف جعل
طالبان تدرك ان التداعيات مهمه ستترتب على
افعالها التي ستغلق الطريق امام تحسن
علاقاتها مع المجتمع الدولي
[موسيقى]
نختم اخبار الساعه من المغرب وبعد سنه من
حادث رحيل الطفل المغربي ريان في اقليم
شفشاون بالمغرب عادت الافراح اخيرا الى
بيت اسره طفل الراحل باعلان ازديان سرير
العائله بمولود ذكر ففي المستشفى المحلي
في مدينه تطوان في شمال المغرب وضعت الام
وسيمه خرشيش ام الراحل ريان وضعت ابنا
ذكرا وكان طبعا سقط الطفل المغربي الراحل
ريان اورام في بئر ضيق قطره اقل من نصف
متر على عمق 32 مترا قرب منزل اسرته في
الاول من شهر فبراير من السنه الماضيه وهو
الحادث الذي شد انظار وقلوب العالم
هذا تكريما لذكرى ريان تعرض العربيه
مشاهدينا الفيلم الوثائقي اثر الفراشه يوم
الاحد المقبل الخامس من فبراير في تمام
التاسعه ونصف بتوقيت السعوديه والسابعه
والنصف بتوقيت المغرب الفيلم من انتاج
وحده الانتاج الوثائقيه في العربيه
ويعود الى مسقط راس الطفل ويكشف المزيد من
التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه انتهت اليكم تذكيرا بابرزها
تختفكو فيلم
بعد فرنسا بريطانيا لا تستبعد ارسال
المقاتلات لكياب والابروب يحذر من تحويل
مولدوفا الى اوكرانيا الجديده
قبل قمه الاتحاد الاوروبي في اوكرانيا
تلمع صورتها بشن حمله واسعه ضد الفساد
تطيح بكبار المسؤولين
الخرطوم تعلن الاتفاق مع اسرائيل لتطبيع
العلاقات وكوهين يؤكد توقيع اتفاق السلام
هذا العام
تسجيل صوتي لمسؤول ايراني في حكومه
روحانية السابقه يحذر من انهيار النظام
ويدعو للاستعداد لمرحله ما بعد خامنين
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده المزيد دائما
يبقى على العربيه وعلى صفحتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]